that's only been two months ago and so
my feelings just don't go away but also
we've both been hurt I hurt him I was
hurt through that and I was hurt through
the relationship that I had
well that was Hannah be talking about
Tyler see with et chest last week but a
lot has happened since then including
this new pics of Tyler on what seems to
be a date with supermodel Gigi Hadid Wow
this happened over the weekend in New
York and they both look pretty dressed
down Gigi in a green jacket with her
hair up in a bun Tyler and a striped tee
and jeans and you better believe we've
got juicy details oh yeah
they left the Dumbo house in Brooklyn
separately but then both got into GG's
chauffeured SUV and went back to her
apartment yeah I told you juicy but this
shouldn't be surprising while the
Bachelorette was airing fans noticed
Gigi follow Tyler on Instagram but the
timing is a little interesting this is
just days after Tyler was spotted
leaving hanabi's house after seemingly
spending the night with her but let's
take it back even before that on the
finale of The Bachelorette we learned
Hanna picked jed over Tyler but that did
not last where does your relationship
stand now I and not with Chad anymore
and then during after the final rose
Hannah asked Tyler out I just thought
maybe we could go for a drink and just
hang it I would love to just tell me
what
I want to continue to be a part of his
life and I think he wants to be a part
of mine but at what capacity I don't
think we know you just yet
but excited to see him and catch up so
we now know that happened but we don't
know where they stand
relationship-wise there's also still
rumors Tyler could be the next Bachelor
I think it'd be a little hard to see him
as the bachelor because they're still
feelings there but I would support him
in his happiness ET spoke with Chris
Harrison this morning and he weighed in
on how Tyler's date with Gigi could
affect his chance of becoming the
bachelor something like that we're
definitely way in the conversation again
if Tyler is bouncing around from girl to
girl and loving the life and enjoying
the limelight which by the way good on
him that's fine if that's what you want
to do right now I don't blame him he's
probably enjoying life really really
well but that's not someone we're gonna
want him have his our bachelor
bachelorette okay so a lot to unpack I
gotta know what you think though what's
going on with Tyler and Hannah what's
going on with Tyler and Gigi will he be
the next Bachelor
let me know and for all the latest keep
it locked to Edie I'm Katie Krause and
bye for now
you
[Applause]
[Music]